de prince
la santé ou sept jeunes riches est ce
que vous êtes heureux
oui et non
[Musique]
alors je sais pas on s'assoit le
fauteuil canapé fauteuils ses fauteuils
ça c'est canapé voilà c'est ça avait
toujours ses petits cousins
oui oui une allée regarder pas je suis
ouvert je vais vers les gens et je mens
pas pourquoi ce serait ce serait un
défaut d'être gentil et de considérer
les gens avec respect la gentillesse et
le respect c'est bien la marque de
fabrique de ce fils attentif qui guette
l'arrivée de la voiture de son père
l'image est apparemment simple et elle
prend toute sa force quand le fils
s'appelle albert de monaco et le père
rainier
lorsque ces scènes ont été prises le
vieux souverain n'avait plus que
quelques mois à vivre
fidèle à sa réputation de bâtisseur il
avait bravé la grisaille et un petit
vent mauvais pour assister à
l'inauguration d'un chantier encore un
celui d'un complexe hôtelier près du
sporting d'été de mona cours le pas est
lent et le regard que porte le monarque
vieillissant sur sa cour
et comme absents
le têt songe-t-il aux chemins parcourus
en l'espace d'un règne record de 56 ans
il a transformé une principauté de
pacotille inconnu en état admis dans les
instances internationales à la
réputation planétaire surtout coup de
génie puisqu'il ne peut pas repousser
des montagnes pour agrandir ce qu'il
appelle lui-même son grand petit état il
augmente de 25% en grignotant sur la mer
il y assure ce chantier ce jour là comme
un passage de flambeau avec kim de
national et aparté entre deux hommes
rapport que l'on disait en même temps de
proximité et de rivalité
[Musique]
le prince rainier laisse un rocher en or
à son fils albert élevé à la dure
âgé aujourd'hui de 47 ans
[Musique]
renier lui n'est qu'un garçon timide de
26 ans seulement lorsqu'il monte sur le
trône le 9 mai 1949 il n'a pas eu une
enfance heureuse avec des parents
désunie il est timide mais déterminé
comme il le montrera très vite
[Musique]
non
et à votre père d'une très forte
personnalité
j'allais presque dire peut-être trop
forte
vers 13h au rite rs que laquelle est le
québécois sera quel est le rapport au
père disons que comme quand j'étais plus
jeune bien sûr il y avait cette autorité
paternelle qui était assez forte et
assez peu incontournable non on essayait
de ne pas faire trop de bêtises pour pas
être exposés aux manifestations de cette
autorité mais oui mais c'est vrai c'est
c'était quelquefois pour tout enfant
assez impressionnant et donc on essaie
de huy oublier très vite ses colères on
essaie de te les oubliés avec lui
[Musique]
on dit que l'armateur grec aristote
onassis avait songé à marié reynier à
marilyn monroe
c'est finalement l'éblouissante grèce
kelly rencontré à l'occasion du festival
de cannes qui chamboulera le coeur du
prince célébrer le 19 avril 1956 le
mariage retransmis par les télévisions
du monde entier sera plus regardée que
le sacre de la reine elizabeth ii
d'angleterre elle même quatre ans
auparavant
l' union donnera naissance à trois
enfants albert caroline et stéphanie
pour moi il y avait peut-être plusieurs
transitions à faire c'est à dire dix
célibataires dit ne pas me marier un
prince sportif c'est aussi albert qui
tient à son jogging question d'habitude
question de bouquets sur l'hygiène tout
le temps parfait j'ai pas fait de longs
footings depuis un certain temps j'aime
bien enfin un vrai footing depuis
pratiquement deux mois alors qu'est ce
que vous appelez au moins
c'est un demi heure entre
new york 7
exit à sion
ah oui je crois que c'est je crois que
je pointe new york c'est une ville assez
extraordinaire lens
parce que là comme énergie si on
arrivant ici on se sent un peu fatigué
grâce à vous
c'est passé c'est cette ville a un
pouvoir de nous
mon quinquennat
la zone
ce tout à fait assez particulier le
lendemain marathon encore mais marathon
diplomatique celui là dans le rôle du
chef d'un des plus petits états au monde
jouant dans la cour des grands aux
nations unies j'ai le plaisir de
souhaiter la bienvenue à son altesse
sérénissime le prince héréditaire albert
de la principauté de monaco et je
l'invite à prendre la parole devant
l'assemblée générale
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général excellences mesdames
messieurs c'est avec grand plaisir que
je vous félicite monsieur le président
pour votre brillante élection à la
présidence de cette 59ème session de
l'assemblée générale
j'ai eu le privilège de fersen
maintenant quelques fois
préside la délégation à l'assemblée
générale depuis
pratiquement dix ans mais c'est toujours
une appréhension un peu c'est un moment
un petit peu particuliers d'abord parce
que cette salle et
gestuelle enfin
ténor mais peu intimidante et puis on
est là devant un parterre souvent de
deux chefs d'état en tout cas de
diplomates chevronnés
et
même si
avec une certaine habitude
à être plus à l'aise c'est toujours je
représente un
quelquefois on ait un lien et on est un
relais et
entre entre des nations
importantes qui ont du mal à traiter
certains dossiers ou ont besoin d'un
appui particulier en cela aussi notre
rôle semble que vous ayez beaucoup
d'amis à écouter la principauté a
beaucoup d'amis
je crois que rencontre que
finalement malgré ce que certaines
mauvaises langues disent la principauté
bien considérer
par l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
albert se sent bien ici et ça se voit il
n'a que 19 ans lorsqu'il entre à
l'université du massachusetts et par la
suite multiplie les expériences
professionnelles dans les domaines de la
banque et de la finance
il connaît l'amérique c'est sa seconde
patrie et new york sa ville de coeur
vous ressentez un peu vous hanter impôts
américains vous êtes à new york ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs
moitié américains oui alors vous donc
défini
veiller comme irlando germaneau alors ça
c'est cet italien du côté de lentilles
etc aussi
mexicain même les mexicains nous et du
son exigence qui peut du côté de votre
mère non cotée mon père du petit colin
on retourne
oui
si que
barça
and as we can
on
il
[Musique]
je lui souhaite la bienvenue en
principauté de monaco à new york
[Musique]
un morceau de principautés top niveau un
peu l'ambassade de monaco sur la 5e
avenue
les américains aiment avoir un contact
direct est plus facile avec entre eux et
donc je dois dire qu'il a ce côté très
américain qui est sympathique et je
trouve qu'il est merveilleux lorsque
nous sommes différents événements d'être
toujours à la disposition de tout le
monde d'être
agréable charmant d'abord un mot gentil
et sincère avec tout le monde donc il a
vraiment l'intelligence du coeur et ça
c'est important d'aider une personne
vous allez viens écouter je crois que
c'est
[Musique]
longtemps
ces idéaux sont sentis de sang
[Musique]
c'est ça le disant
qu'est ce que vous avez qu'est ce que
nous faisons un peu tout
ça dépend
chose qui
sorti un peu
là
vous verrez
on
ouvrez la section ucsa marc leval
[Musique]
pas régulièrement mais je les ai
toujours les arts on la regarde et on
les a vus en famille un peu après
c'était un peu difficile de les voir non
il n'ya pas que des films intellos à la
vie et aux médecins de musique mais quoi
l'entente madonna
avait des goûts éclectiques j'aimais
beaucoup ce que je faisais
ce que vous êtes une connerie et vous la
chanson je vois j'ai chanté alger
chantier à l'université de bangui
chorale voix leur accord risque de
prendre du conseil
les rayons je fais pas ça pour
partagez pas si médiatique considérable
chose dont vous avez secret du bonnet
d'âne en tout temps enfin pas uniquement
parce qu'on digère encore et encore
maintenant
ras-le-bol
vous êtes jamais dit avec une espèce de
danville été jeté l'épongé le partir au
bout du monde
on entend tout ça je basculais va
devenir très dur les couloirs ça vous
êtes arrivé à vous aimer n'a pas trop le
temps d'y penser d'activités non c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment j'aimerais
prendre de vraies vacances c'est allé
assez loin
et puis avoir des journées tranquilles
et si vous n'étiez pas
héritiers dont à coacher prince de
monaco ont pensé ça vous auriez fait
quoi
une idée de ce que vous auriez paix
comme métier sur effet d'être quelque
chose dans le sport et dans dans
l'éducation ou sportives pour les jeunes
c'était j'étais moniteur d'attaquants
d'accord si c'est au savini ça valait
bien plus on s'en va d'ici
[Applaudissements]
en inspectant oui c'est ça fait reporter
[Musique]
le prince n'est pas homme à se coucher
tôt et ça tombe bien attendu dans une
boîte branchée de manhattan albert y
retrouve amis et parents qui ont tous en
commun d'avoir une jolie fortune
une soirée au profit de la fondation
princesse grace dont le principal
soutien est le célèbre joaillier alberto
rip aussi venus pour l'occasion présenté
ses plus belles pierres parmi les plus
beaux bijoux du monde et là je crois que
c'est quelque chose que vous voulez nous
montrer ben c'est le dernier ruby
anciens que j'ai trouvé c'est 200 de
pierres anciennes coupé brieuc sont 54
d'origine car c'est un des plus grands
au monde dans cette dans cette coupe
et là je vous montre le plus grand rugby
qu'il ya maintenant ce le marché parce
que ça c'est failli 60 carats du pays
herman et ce magnifique merci à l'aller
nouvelle mine de birmanie qui sort
maintenant l'ensemble est vendu un bien
on est
les deux mille ans et demi tous donc
deux millions et demi un million et demi
sa gentillesse et son
sa force de volonté et les employeurs
[Musique]
nous
quand albert retrouve la rue et la nuit
new yorkaise il n'est pas fâché d'être
reconnu et interpellé par une
admiratrice marocaine
direction un restaurant à la mode c'est
un paradoxe chez cet homme sportif mais
à qui la fête ne fait pas peur même
lorsqu'il doit repasser l'atlantique le
lendemain matin aux aurores pour monter
par certains escaliers un peu
sens-tu au raid mais voilà alors je sais
pas si vous voulez vous voir là où aller
au bout là bas là c'est toute cette
dalle est au dessus des garages du
palais ou qui ont été aménagés depuis
quelques années maintenant un jardin et
puis vous avez au fond bien sûr là la
tour guide de l'horloge
la fois mon le bureau de mon père est le
moins savait que
le palais est en plusieurs phases a été
d'abord suivie des dommages pendant
les périodes de son histoire il ya
encore certaines parties du palais qui
sont plus vers la vers latour de serre
aval donc vers l'est dans les jardins
qui date
encore
qui donne encore du potentiel c 'est pas
la toute première forteresse tu skies a
pas un côté un peu prison dorée et je
crois que le mot prison est un peu fort
mais disons que et d'aurélia au palais
oui aussi
mais c'est pour cela qu'il ya aussi
quelques lieux où l'on peut s'échapper
où on est un petit peu plus libre des
symboles nourrissent à souhait mais dans
la situation qui est la vôtre c'est
difficile de le faire discrètement on y
arrive on y arrive je vais pas vous
livrer tous les secrets mais on on peut
y arriver on connaît l'amour pour votre
mère
donc j'aimerais vous nous en parler un
petit peu c'est peut-être un être tout à
fait exceptionnel qui a nous a tous
bien sûr ces enfants en premier
à façonner un petit peu notre autre
façon d'être et notre ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui on a dit quelquefois que
seul du haut valais lui peser un petit
peu c'est pour ça qu'elle dès qu'on
pouvait emporter
on va commencer quelque part en aller
notre notre propriété du montage elle ou
alors là c'était c'est une vie plus
simple qu'il aimait aussi elle faisait
la cuisine elle avait des activités tout
à fait simple et vous avez été épargné
par cette presse très particulier votre
votre soeur stéphanie
quand il a quand même été très affecté
par la mort de notre mère et elle était
donc aussi dans un état un petit peu
affaibli un petit peu traumatique
pendant très longtemps après l'accident
et je crois que
et la presse cette constante attention
et bien il ya des moments où ça s'est
très mal passée et après c'est difficile
de se rendre maître de cela et de et
d'essayer de d'avoir une vie privée
normal c'est probablement à cause de
cette figure de cette cassure de cette
blessure jamais refermée de l'on sait et
que l'on sent albert si proche de cette
petite soeur il vient même l'admirer
dans ses oeuvres et l'encourager
lorsqu'il joue au football comme il aime
le faire quand il le peut en rencontre
amicale
une rencontre presque entre copains
[Musique]
[Rires]
non
[Musique]
alors qu'on marque ne peut pas les
laisser notre sueur fait des bons matchs
contre l'équipe du cirque et même si les
les éléments sont contre nous nous
allons mettre la pression et nous allons
je l'espère égaliser pourquoi pas
marquer le but de la victoire
aujourd'hui mère de 40 ans avec trois
enfants stéphanie a gardé un charme
juvénile une spontanéité et ce petit
rien d'espièglerie qui laisse penser
qu'elle ne se prend décidément jamais
vraiment au sérieux
il est pour qui changement de décor
albert arrive ici dans son club en
patron à la et ce monaco
bon
j'étais à beausoleil que chaque fois les
gens ils voulaient tout fait rire à
chaque homme là comme ça
pendant mille fois pardon
non un peu dérangeant les projets ok
demain aller
il
quelques mots sur scène vous avez peur
qu'ils disent du mal
il donne son avis sur les joueurs
bon il a son avis comme si on vous savez
qu'un ici à 15000 personnes au stade de
15 me donner une analyse sur les joueurs
sur l'entraîneur surtout sur les choix
non oui oui oui
son avis est un peu plus importante de
samarie ça m'arrive d'abord les
discussions plus précise avec lui mais
c'est normal je tiens donc
mais bon il a demandé années de pratique
et d'un coeur il connaît ne connais bien
le plus important
à chaque fois que j'ai couleur lui dire
pour les joueurs pour devenir sa
présence quelque chose et un soutien et
et ce quelque chose d'important pour
pour les joueurs
oui c'est ça ma préparation ils se
sentent honorés oui oui et puis sont
fiers et puis bon c'est ça c'est sa
principauté et d'un club puis bon il
connaît la plupart des joueurs aussi
donc il ya beaucoup de l'affinité est le
joueur qui vous vraiment vous donne du
bonheur je crois qu'on a mal de très
bons joueurs comme
comme ce qu'il à chico vivait il ya
plusieurs joueurs qui sont en équipe de
france il ya des joueurs étrangers comme
saviola comme chez wendel qui sont des
on est très très bon joueur au pays
respectifs en tout cas sur le papier
comme comme le long d une équipe très
compétitive vous vibrer avec eux quoi
dire quand ils perdent de leur rue leur
fait dire que vous avez été déçu par le
jeu d'un janet l je leur dis souvent
directement mais je crois qu'il faut il
faut pas trop il faut pas trouver un
câble et quand ça va mal au contraire il
faut être face ici c'est vraiment classe
trophy plans représentaient mais je
crois qu'il faut plutôt les encourager
plutôt amener du positif et
essayez de seuil et d'aller de l'avant
essayer de conquérir des titres
[Musique]
la vie privée des princes ne serait
décidément pas toujours un conte de fées
objet de tous les regards
entouré par les plus jolies femmes
albert reste l'un des plus beaux partie
du gotha européen
ses amis le disent grand séducteur et
pourtant
comble de l'ironie une méchante rumeur
insistante et insidieuse voudrait que
l'homme à femmes
en fait tu n'aimerais pas les femmes et
serait homosexuel
où
j'ai toujours essayé de protéger les
relations les femmes que j'ai eue pour
les protéger elle aussi alors c'est vrai
qu'on me voit pas souvent en
manifestations officielles si si vous
voulez accompagnée d'une amie donc on va
imaginer tout de suite à peut-être
qu'ils n'aiment pas les femmes
ou peut-être qu'il aimait de au fait
qu'en fin de l'année c'est du n'importe
quoi les gens qui me connaissent ma
famille mes amis et les gens qui
comptent pour moi ça qui je suis
savent que je suis des milliers de
kilomètres des milliers d'années lumière
de ce que certains veulent que ça t'a
prétendent que je suis est-ce que c'est
pas tout simplement parce que vous avez
pas mariés je crois que effectivement ça
peut avoir mais ils payent rien mais il
ya bien sûr eu des tentatives de me
rapprocher de certaines personnes
certaines de façon ostensible et est
visible d'autre part des chemins très
détourné
j'ai toujours on a essayé de vous marier
ou voilà on a chacun sont amis et
chacun une période de la vie où l'on
pense qu'il faut changer de il faut
changer son statut et sa sa façon de lui
et si si c'est pas le si ce n'est pas
encore le moment si on estime que c'est
ce que j'ai estimé que c'était pas je
n'étais pas encore entré dans cette
phase là de ma vie je vais pas
précipiter les choses je vais pas me
marier pour faire plaisir à certaines
personnes dans ce domaine très précis et
très très personnel vous n'entendez pas
vous laisser dicter votre conduite non
les gens nous voient comme un bon joueur
et je sais pas si c'est si ça ne
qualifie vraiment tout ce que j'ai fait
j'ai essayé de profiter de mes instants
de liberté le mieux possible
alors si c'est à ces fâcheuses quand on
appelle quelqu'un d'engeances et il ya
toujours une partie des genres at il un
parti une connotation qui n'est pas
sérieuse donc je vais pas moi je vais
pas vous dire que je suis un enjeu
je m'estime pas l'être ce que j'ai pu
faire c'est que j'essaie de profiter de
mes instants de liberté avec mes amis
le plus que j'ai pu je pense que je
pense qu'on peut pas me reprocher oui
j'ai déjà été c'était pas le bon moment
pour pouvoir les oui disons qu'il ya des
6es relation avait duré un certain temps
de plus peut-être
perspective du mariage aurait été aurait
été là mais ça ne s'est pas produit le
gala de la croix rouge c'est le grand
rendez vous mondain d'une principauté
qui s'y connaît pourtant mondanités ici
important que le prince arrivé au volant
sa voiture veille personnellement à ce
que tout se passe comme prévu
voyant les moindres détails avec ses
collaborateurs
[Musique]
joli passage à rennes
je suis très
conciliant et arrangeant
alors mai
pour ça qu'on avait commencé un peu plus
tôt les autres fois fait c'était aussi
la d'entreprendre tout le monde contre
pied mais c'était aussi parce que je
sais très bien de parme ma petite
expérience de
tenter quelques années de délinquants
rouge
beaucoup de gens qui sont morts juste
après le spectacle si je prends
l'ascenseur il me suit
c'est eux
on en est
est ce que vous serez installé par là
bas la famille vous allez voir me dire
en anglais aussi
c'est ensuite de là on descend l'écran
connu
côté
ce que vous
le taux satisfait le prince repart aussi
vite qu'il est venu laissant à d'autres
le soin d'accueillir les premières stars
quote
[Musique]
c'est l'embouteillage le plus chic du
monde autour ne seront point dans un
ballet étourdissant se succèdent des
voitures de prestige dont pas une ne
vaut moins de deux cent mille euros
[Musique]
quand on joue
vous
en descendent de somptueuses créatures
qui doivent probablement à leur jeunesse
de se retrouver au bras de vieux
messieurs très argentés ou des dames
d'un certain âge à moins que ce soit
d'un âge certain qu'ils elles doivent
beaucoup à leur culture y est ou alors
chirurgien esthétique tous eu plus ou
moins beau monde se bouscule pour
côtoyer les stars souvent des habitués
comme woody allen paul anka loire des
années 60 ou gina lollobrigida
et le clou de la soirée c'est bien sûr
l'arrivée de la famille princière au
grand complet renier son fils albert et
princesses caroline et stéphanie la
princesse antoinette soeur de renier et
l'époux de caroline ernst august de
hanovre extraordinaire saga que celle de
cette famille dont le pouvoir
d'attraction est intacte
les joies les peines les amours les
échecs les drames de la famille royale
que la france n'a plus continue de
fasciner fruit d'un subtil cocktail où
se mêle argent gloire et beauté voulue
par regnier l'hypermédiatisation de la
famille de monaco lasserre autant
qu'elle l'a pénalise fun pour la
publicité du rocher elle est diversement
vécu par les enfants princiers qui dès
leur plus jeune âge sont en permanence
sous l'objectif des photographes
[Musique]
est ce que vous regrettez cette
surexposition médiatique
vous avez encore chercher finalement
cette popularité fait partie d'un
ensemble avec le recul vous dit pas on a
trop trop donné ou quoi que vous fassiez
vous serez toujours pourchassés et on
était poursuivie de façon beaucoup plus
systématique que maintenant par par une
horde de paparazzi et c'était
extrêmement désagréable dans la vie de
tous les jours en attendant une
il était à l'affût du moindre mois de
manifestations de vie privée il n'était
pas là souvent lors des manifestations
officielles ça ne les intéresse pas mais
j'ai des souvenirs de d'une période où
j'étais assez souvent à paris et où mes
soeurs étaient souvent à paris on était
pourchassé le le mot n'est pas trop fort
par une dizaine de photographes
on n'a jamais convoqué la presse pour
pour partir avec nous en vacances nous
retrouver quelquefois je me rappelle
lorsqu'on est en vacances de ski
lorsque j'étais enfant en suisse et bien
on devait offrir une séance poser pour
faire photographier finalement nous
laisse tranquille silence s'étaient
c'est toute la journée tous les jours
malgré la séance organisée ils vous
laissez pas alors il y en a qui jouaient
le jeu est qui et qui repartait après ça
et on a bien sûr qu'ils continuaient à
se cacher dans les sapins
[Musique]
pour régner ce sera son dernier gala de
la croix rouge
il semble déjà ailleurs et ses enfants
se montrent particulièrement attentionné
les convives eux semblent avoir compris
que ces applaudissements sont aussi des
adieux
[Musique]
en même temps s'il en est qui ne boudent
pas leur plaisir ce sont les invités
payant qui vont avoir droit à un dîner
digne des repas du roi soleil avant
d'entendre la star made in us et lionel
richie
[Applaudissements]
moi
chacun des mille convives à payer 2000
euros mais c'est pour la bonne cause
puisque qu'ils iront à la croix rouge
monégasque reste que cet argent qui
coule à flot et poulet aussi beaucoup
d'or à leur argent sale ou pas des
rapports français accuse régner à gérer
son pays comme une entreprise
mais albert refu il est jamais dit que
c'était une machine à faire de l'argent
je ne sais pas si moi j'ai jamais
entendu dire mon père de sa bouche
monaco est une machine à faire de
l'argent je crois que c'était propos ou
non une présentation qui a été faussée
où tu as fait exagéré les accusations de
blanchiment d'argent
personne n'a vraiment répondu au plus
haut niveau si on veut revenir au plus
haut niveau je pense à la famille
princière
mais s'il faut qu'à chaque fois le
prince la famine et monte en première
ligne
il y a un gouvernement pour traiter de
ces questions très spécifiques
mais à partir du moment où monaco attire
et accueille 2
presque exclusivement des grandes
fortunes comment savoir d'où vient
l'argent bien parce que il y à des
systèmes bancaires qui est assez bien
régulé maintenant qui depuis un an -
années mais qui est beaucoup plus
vigilant mais le problème existe
ailleurs promis existe dans notre
voisinage immédiat aussi vous savez que
monaco et la côte d'azur sont à un point
d'attrait santé des lieux extrêmement
attractif nous n'y pouvons rien
l'évolution notre évolution économique a
été de telle façon qu'elle qu'elle est
attractive pour beaucoup de personnes et
malheureusement quelques personnes qui
sont mal intentionnées ou qui ont des
fonds qui dans la provenance est
extrêmement troubles lorsque vous
règlerez ou souhaité vous essaierez de
moraliser tout ça encore plus je sais
pas si on peut parler de moralisation
mais en tout cas je serais tu as fait
intransigeant sur c'est sur ces
problèmes
[Musique]
c'est son bureau volant toujours flanqué
d'un de ses deux aides de camp des
officiers français comme c'est depuis
toujours la règle ici le colonel jouant
albert passe moins de temps à monaco que
dans le reste du monde à bord d'un
falcon flambant neuf que pour un peu il
pourrait piloter lui même
[Musique]
l'intérêt c'est pourquoi j'avais fait
des cours théoriques
il ya sa banque
naissance donc là on peut pas vous
laisser les commandes de l'avion
pour lactalis arrive non non
c'est le prince voyageurs par excellence
diplomate vrp de luxe même s'il ne se
reconnaît pas dans cette formule
désormais chef d'état ce ne sont que
mission sur tous les fronts en même
temps diplomatiques économiques
culturelles humanitaires touristique
même
[Musique]
rien de bien
accueil martial en bulgarie avec la
pompe réservée aux plus grands par le
président de la république lui-même
programme serré avec échange de
décoration visite de la cathédrale
alexandre nevski l'un des symboles de
sofia et rencontre avec un homme au
destin unique l'ancien roi siméon ii
chassé en 1946 est revenu comme premier
ministre en 2008
d'habitude c'est les locataires de
maisons plus haut que j'appelle kunst
actuel évêque réception souriante par le
sénateur maire de strasbourg tout étonné
de données du monseigneur c'est la
formule utilisée lorsqu'on s'adresse au
prince
mais l'événement est d'importance
en principauté de metz demain en conseil
de l'europe c
c'est merci à très bientôt
donc ok ok j'adresse après l'onu en 1993
et 6 ans de dures négociations monaco
est admis au conseil de l'europe
un pas de géant pour ce royaume de poche
[Musique]
pendant cinq heures
travaux
mais comme il faut être décidément
partout à la fois le prince ne peut pas
ne pas honorer de sa présence la foire
internationale de sa ville monaco des
rencontres sympathiques auquel il se
plie avec patience et bonne grâce qu'il
se voit affublé d'un burnous sauce quand
du maroc ou proposer le spectacle d'un
spiderman plus bondissant que
convaincant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps d'un voyage éclair à shanghai
pour vanter les vertus touristique du
rocher et albert revient à l'ambassade
de monaco à paris pour décorer des
citoyens méritants s'avère donc à son
arrivée se passer ici monsieur nicomaque
mettez là bas
on n'en est pas encore là conseillère
donc se mettra pas si morose et patrick
se mettra ici moi qui se dernière le
camp saber et monsieur l'ambassadeur je
vais me mettre dans un endroit là
lorsque tout le monde est prêt à verser
ans donc je vais désormais s'ouvrir en
commençant par commande
portant promotions et nominations dans
l'ordre de saint charles est promu au
grade de commandeur monsieur pierre
delvolvé vice président du tribunal
suprême
[Musique]
et puis sur l'agenda princier le voyage
de l'émotion au sri lanka pays martyr
balayée par le tsunami 31 mille morts et
huit cent mille déplacés
je suis heureux aussi aujourd'hui
ensemble nous puissions célébrer cet
esprit de solidarité de générosité qui
anime cette belle entreprise collective
là-bas très loin monaco apporter confort
soutien aide matérielle et morale pas
seulement un déplacement médiatisé parmi
d'autres mais la marque d'une
authentique compassion pour les plus
malheureux
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui dans la vie vous fait
avancer
et qu'est-ce qui vous révolte ce qui est
révoltant c'est cette injustice c'est là
c'est des grands problèmes de ce monde
c'est là c'est la faim dans le monde
trouve que c'est inadmissible août
l'ailier encore prêt de près d'un
milliard de personnes dans le monde qui
meurent de faim ou qui ne mangent pas à
leur faim tous les jours c'est tous les
drames qui qui touche l'enfance alors
c'est lié aussi à cela c'est lié aux
problèmes de la pauvreté dans le monde
d'une manière générale tout ce qui en
découle
la malnutrition la maladie et puis ce
qui donne espoir c'est aussi lorsque
l'on peut voir personnellement que l'on
a apporté quelque chose
une petite amélioration dans la vie de
quelqu'un d'un enfant lorsqu'on voit
dans ce jeu le la joie et le privilège
de pouvoir voir salle
lorsqu on améliore le quotidien d'un
enfant c'est ce sourire là c'est sur ces
remerciements là je crois que c'est ça
qui nous fait dire qu'il n'ya plus que
l'on a encore de l'espoir passé combien
de temps d'argent le bureau poussée des
parents il ya des jours où je passe je
peux passer douze heures plus et des
jours que
vingt minutes je passe en coup de vent
entre entre deux manifestations
officielles savez jamais quand même
enfin vous voyez j'ai des choses qui
soient un petit peu en retard
et voilà il ya pas mal de choses en
attente
il faut voir qu'il faut lire on essaie
de faire
[Musique]
le 18 septembre 1982 une famille plongée
dans la douleur accompagne grâce à sa
dernière demeure
c'est dans cette même cathédrale ya lieu
le jour de la fête nationale
une grande messe solennelle célébrée par
monseigneur barsi archevêque de monaco
dans cette principauté où l'église est
religion d'état
les rapports entre le clergé et la
famille princière sont étroits
c'est d'ailleurs sur l'insistance de
renier que l'évêché de monaco dépendant
de nice devient un archevêché en 1961
pour tous les membres de la famille
princière et de la maison souveraine
que dieu vous maintiennent dans sa paix
et dans sa joie les rangées réservées à
la famille princière se font plus
clairsemés 23 ans après rainier iii donc
rejoint son épouse laissant albert une
tâche à laquelle il dit s'être préparés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont des prêts sur je n'ai jamais dit
que je n'étais pas prêt et vous avez
j'avais dire une équipe vous je sais à
peu près d une personne qui pourrait
être autour de moi mais il faut une mise
en place qu israël qui sera échelonné
dans le temps dans n'importe quel pays
n'importe quel ministère n'importe
quelle grande société
quand il ya quelqu'un qui est à la tête
de cette société le ce pays il ya
forcément des il amène avec lui d'aider
des personnes de nouvelles votre père a
été le prince bâtisseur vous de quelle
façon vous aimeriez copains votre future
feuille il est trop tôt pour me coller
une étiquette on colle pas un numéro de
départ à quelqu'un avant de avant qu'il
parte
désormais prince souverain de monaco
mais aussi duc de valentinois compte de
carladès baron de calvin et du bruit
seigneur de saint rémy cire de matignon
compte de torigni baron de saint lô de
la lutine hier et de hambye duc de
mazarin et de mayenne prince de
château-porcien comte de ferrette de
belfort de thann et de rosemont baron
d'altkirch seigneur d'issenheim marquis
de chiny compte de longjumeau et marquis
de guiscard son altesse sérénissime
albert ii va devoir assurer et assumer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
médaille d'honneur de troisième classe
en bronze 15 ans de service jean-marc
oberdorff caporal à la compagnie des
sapeurs pompiers au balcon avec ses
soeurs caroline et stéphanie la fille de
caroline alexandra et son beau-frère
enst august de hanovre le prince a déjà
tous les attributs et la posture du
pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
l'homme qui ne sait pas s'il est heureux
ou s'il ne l'est pas est désormais seul
maître à bord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
et